about a week ago John McCain and Barack
Obama both went to Southern California
to Rick Warren the author of purpose
driven life his big megachurch
Saddleback and he hosted this forum
where they would talk about matters of
faith and politics you know why they
want to be President their vision for
the future of America and when I took a
look at with their answers to one
particular question he asked both of
them this question which is of the
existing judges on the Supreme Court who
would you not have nominated so McCain's
answer was that he would not have
appointed the forward liberals who are
on the course which is Stephen Souter
Ginsburg Breyer now this is this is a
give really pandering answer because
here's the great maverick US senator who
as a senator voted to confirm three of
these four individuals Stevens the only
one he didn't vote to confirm that's
just because Stevens is nominated to the
Supreme Court you know two decades
before McCain is a senator so if he if
McCain cared so much about these liberal
judges you know where is where was his
outrage over the past ten years or more
it means it's pretty clear that McCain
you know he's running for president
obviously he needs to appeal to
conservative voters he needs to show
them that yeah he's you know he's soft
an immigration he's soft on torture in
their opinion but this is a guy who's
going to appoint conservative judges so
now McCain suddenly cares about who sits
on the Supreme Court and these judges
who were no problem for him before these
justices are now a big problem for him
it's a ver pandering answer Barack Obama
gets the same question in his response
which also is quite clearly pandering to
his base also in my opinion was
extremely revealing which is that
Clarence Thomas that's that's who he
starts with he would not have nominated
Clarence Thomas to the Supreme Court and
the reason he gives is that Thomas at
the time 1991 was not as strong enough
thinker or jurist to to hold that
position now that what does this sound
like I was just like let's think about
this for a second this sounds a lot like
the classic argument against affirmative
action which is that an under qualified
applicant gets the position they get the
job because of their race religion or
gender if Clarence Thomas in 1991 was
obviously qualified soon on Supreme
Court the American Bar Association they
rated him qualified for the position
they do that for every presidential
nominee this
guy went to Yale Law School is a guy who
had been a US District Court Judge he's
clearly qualified at the time but more
than that he's been on the Supreme Court
for more than a decade now whether you
agree with him or not he's a very
conservative judge he makes no secret
about that I mean I personally don't
agree with many of his decisions but
whether you agree with Thomas or not
he's clearly qualified to sit on the
Supreme Court he's proven himself a
capable justice so why is Barack Obama
bringing up this decade old assertion a
demonstrably false assertion that that
Clarence Thomas wasn't wasn't capable
wasn't up was basically wasn't up to the
job at the time it's clear that Barack
Obama he's pandering to his base John
McCain was pandering to his bathe both
both of these guys you know we have the
Maverick we have the candidate of change
and hope we can believe in and they're
both pandering they're both doing what
politicians do every election and we
shouldn't be fooled by the flowery
rhetoric that they're both also trying
to give us